good
morning millennials welcome back
to the morning toast happy thursday
happy what should be the fourth episode
of the week but it's only the second
because and i'm so glad this worked out
perfectly i'm so glad that you were
scheduled to be the co-host today
because we have to come on and discuss
what we've been through yes so ben is
here he was already scheduled to be here
but before we dive in and do anything
like
we have something to say we've been hit
no we've seen hell hours the devil
entered my body
our home was hit earlier this week with
the noto virus which apparently is a
thing that everyone knows about we
didn't know it's like the seasonal
stomach flu but apparently this year's
is a real [__]
we okay so over the weekend
we went out on saturday saturday night
we go to bed and ben is up all night
both ends
and we're like
what the [__] honestly i didn't really
take it seriously i was gonna say we're
not anything claudia is asleep as i am
hurling
[__] like
like
again i can't stress enough she said
both ends
both ends and so i thought it was food
poisoning so i was more than happy to
like you know help when i woke up i was
very helpful yes you were when you woke
up you were helpful i wasn't worried
about you know getting anything from you
because i thought it was [__] food
poisoning yes it was not and then monday
after the show i'm like sitting here
typing like putting an episode up and i
feel as though i've been hit by a bus
i'm like oh my god i have to go home so
i'm in the uber with like my head
hanging out the window because like i
needed fresh air i'm like i think i'm
gonna vomit and i get home and i
literally collapse in my bed for four
hours i just fell asleep which is i mean
i love to nap but that's insane like one
o'clock
and i woke up at five o'clock and it was
over like it had started the devil had
entered me as well
and my st like i just can't and it was
literally 36 hours of non-stop torture i
haven't had a i mean i must look we must
look so thin like what we've been
through i haven't eaten a full meal
seriously since sunday i lost 12 pounds
it's so cool actually if you look at my
google search it's literally how to use
a virus to start a diet jump start a
diet like how do you use it to jump
start and leave
the weight off and what i read is that
you can't puke fat so like that that
doesn't like it's not like really a
thing
like we will bounce back to our original
weight yes no but when i tell you again
i've been i've been instructed not to
get too graphic because what we
witnessed in each other this weekend i
will not get overly graphic but what i
will say
is that at one point
early saturday morning six in the
morning i'm hurled over the toilet and
all of a sudden stop stop i just
take a stop stop stop
stop seriously stop stop stop stop like
that's too much i told you not to get
too graphic and that's the most graphic
part of it so what are you doing
on what is that thing called no just
shut up seriously shut up shut the floor
shut up
it was just we've seen things in each
other that we can never unsee no we
can't i do feel as though our marriage
is stronger than ever it is
and just know that there were you know
lots of clothing lots of towels lots of
garbage bags lots of lots of heating
pads that we had to throw out that's
let's just stick with that fine i think
that's a good assessment of everyone
needing to know what yeah yes rest in
peace to that heating pad just it really
it didn't deserve what it got what you
did and then by the way ben ruined the
heating pad i love that you're literally
talking in circles around it yeah of
course i [__] on the heating pad she
gave me a heating pad to help me i woke
up
i woke up shut up and i [__] on it so
shut up
ben by the way i have like a 60 heating
pad that's so big
ben ruined it and when i thought he had
food poisoning i was like you know what
i'll get myself another one
and it'll be okay then i had to go
through the devil's disease without my
[__] heating pad no you had a heating
pad you got me a shitty one from
walgreens that was literally literally
four inches by four inches my heating
pad at home is literally like 36 by 36.
no it's an unbelievable heating pad
yeah it was ruined it's like as big as
this couch it's huge it's huge and it
was ruined so to go through the
notovirus without my stupid heating pad
like that was crippling i'm just saying
people are like covid nodo ben i was
thinking the same thing the way that the
entire like economy world shut down for
covid like this is worse this is worse
and apparently this happens every year
and literally just by being in the same
room as someone transferred not six feet
600 feet transferred it was i was
thinking the same thing i'm like this is
what we should be shutting down for as
well yeah and this is crippling and
literally the
the out both ends of it all i promise
could kill every every senior citizen
they're dead they get this they're dead
you guys like okay so here's the thing
this is an informative podcast so the
first thing i want to say is that if
someone in your household is like
starting to feel nauseous like it's not
food poisoning it's highly contagious
and hunker down first of all i didn't
even know this thing existed like if i
had known i would have just like
approached it differently i had no idea
the second thing i want to tell you like
if it does and i now know people who are
getting it and everyone's dming me so
here is like my number one tip and it's
such a good tip and unfortunately i had
to learn from you not having this tip
if you catch this virus and you find
yourself like having to puke
please do yourself a favor and sit on
the toilet while you puke puke into a
garbage bag a garbage bin lit puke on
the floor literally do anything else do
not remove your ass from the toilet
because you will regret it okay that's
all i have to say and just just as for
the girls out there who go through this
virus while on their period because the
whole thing time i was thinking like if
i had my period right now like i would
just i would i would not be okay yes
and
dramamine
ammonium imodium pedialyte
yeah see
i have a problem with pediatrics i know
you do you were like watering down your
pediatrics ideolite is so sugary it's
electrically
no but you can get electrolytes
electrolytes are like salts electrolytes
aren't sugar no nothing electrolytes are
salt oh really
yeah are they okay
google it google it i don't think so i'm
pretty sure electrolytes are salt no
they're like neutrons you know protons
jimmies
are they salted salts no
wait you're so smart i'm so pretty yeah
i am they're definitely not fruit punch
well it was strawberry flavored
pediatrics for kids yeah it was way too
much i thought it tasted disgusting and
i need pedialyte to make a watered-down
version that has just as much
electrolytes but it's drinkable they do
they have like pedialyte light they have
like pedialyte popsicles oh they do yeah
they have like a ton of different i just
got the only one that go puff had
because like we were [__] desperate
so you're welcome by the way also shout
out go puff
shout out go puff literally
life-saving technology 15 minutes i got
the imodium 15 minutes i got the
dramamine 15 minutes i got the saltines
15 minutes you could get the spritz in
california
only okay for now for now um okay so i
feel as though we've grossed everyone
out enough that is where we were at i
apologize for missing both episodes of
the toast like of course jackie leaves
it up to me to do the toast and i get
the stomach flu but i'm back i'm not
gonna lie i'm not a hundred percent but
i can now sit here for an hour and not
crap my pants so
that's why we're here yeah thank you to
everyone i'm really sorry for missing
both episodes but we're back and we are
gonna do deer toasters today because we
were supposed to do it on wednesday's
episode
so ben is going to join me we've got
lots of news since it's been a few days
we've got your toasters and we've got
ben and honestly that's all we need
agreed and the fact that you're even
apologizing if you guys could see her
this woman was sick as a dog did you
feel bad for me
here's the deal i didn't know
no no i felt bad for you because you
gave it to me i thought
see this is the narrative that i don't
like you gave to me like somebody gave
it to me yeah of course but you brought
it into our house like what were you
doing on saturday that you like where
were you hanging out that you picked up
you were together yeah exactly what were
you doing i don't know being together no
you brought it home maybe you picked it
up
gave it to me
and then i gave it back to you and the
first time you got it yeah you didn't
have symptoms yeah
that's what happened okay that's what
happened okay um you brought it home
thank you so much and
anything else you want to say about the
disease before we go no it's a terrible
disease i i'm telling you i'm still like
80 it's just it really takes your soul
oh it crushes your spirit it's gone it's
gone my spirit is gone my will to live
like it was just
awful no it's bad it's bad and also like
there's a real joy in life when you feel
like you're going to have like a nice
fart
like it's really
it's really nice to fart like if you
need to fart
fart everybody if everybody's going to
agree
you need a fart it feels great sometimes
a fart can change your day around and
sometimes and not sometimes now this
disease has taken the fart from me
because now i'm afraid every single time
i'm like oh that's a fart nope maybe
you're [__] your pants no you're
questioning every fart i'm questioning
every fart i'm so sorry this disease
made me question everything you'll get
your spirit back don't worry i don't
know i think you will
i'll never fart the same we're different
people like 100 we are
um but we have enough of a spirit to do
today's show um thank you ben for
joining us again the last time you were
here the reviews were rave
and when josh peck was here on friday so
many people first of all they loved the
episode and they also said like they
totally see how you and josh peck are
best friends because you guys we got so
many comments saying how similar you
guys were yeah i mean josh is the best
number one you gonna read his book of
course when
i don't know look i don't read books i
read claudia's book that was the first
book that i read since i read half of
what's that uh book that turned into a
curious incident of the dog in the
middle of the night i read the curious
incident of the dog of the night great
book you only read half no i think i
read the whole thing who ended up
killing the dog
i don't remember the guy's dad yeah i
remember and then then there was a
wonderful broadway show that claudia
said she hated uh ben said he saw this
broadway show he's like remember that
book curious incident they turned into a
broadway show you guys should see it so
what do we do we buy tickets for the
whole family we're sitting in this play
and we're like we have been hoodwinked
this is trash so that's the last time we
ever take a broadway recommendation from
you interesting um okay let's dive in
because we've got a lot to cover
in today's no uh how does it go here are
the fast five stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast beat the
crunch so annoying um and today's
episode is brought to you by caraway
it's time to ditch the chemicals with
caraway's home caraway homes non-toxic
cookware and bakeware collections so you
can make healthier cooking a piece of
cake
cowaway's home caraway homes non-toxic
kitchenwares are all designed for the
modern home and a fee and they feature a
chemical-free ceramic coating so food
can be prepared with peace of mind that
no hard-to-pronounce compound will leach
into your healthy ingredients so caraway
home is so great because it's non-toxic
but also the reason why i love it is
because it's sickeningly stunning they
have gorgeous cookware
so many colors every time they drop a
color it's literally like balenciaga um
i have the frying pan i have a bunch of
their products they're really really
great they work super well super easy to
clean and non-toxic so it's great to for
for your family and to bring into your
home visit caraway home dot com toast
take advantage of this limited time
offer of 10 off your next purchase the
deal
is exclusive for our listeners so visit
caraway home
c-a-r-a-w-a-y home dot com toast or use
code toast to check out caraway is
non-toxic cookware made modern non-toxic
easy cooking naturally slick surface
means minimal oil or butter for a slide
off the pan eggs and easy cleaning
today's episode is also brought to you
by sunbasket sunbasket delivers the joys
of eating with bold flavors organic
produce and sustainable seafood and
meats their award-winning chefs are
constantly innovating with new recipes
and global tastes to keep it interesting
each week with dozens of options you can
put dinner on autopilot with easy to
prep meal kits that impress for date
night or win over the picky eaters in
your family whether you eat vegetarian
paleo gluten free or low carb
high protein sun sunbasket has something
to check every box set up weekly
delivery and skip a week when you need
to it's simple easy and you'll love it
old habits die hard so if you're looking
to update your meal time if that's like
something you want to do in the new year
start cooking more whether it's to save
money from ordering in or just trying to
eat healthier try sun basket a lot of
the meals are super delicious and
they're very very specific so if you
have like strict dietary needs which we
are very strict dietary needed household
um you'll find something that you like
on some basket for your kids or for you
and right now sunbasket is offering 90
off and a free gift when you order just
go to sunbasket.com
toast and enter the promo code toast at
checkout that's s-u-n-b-a-s-k-e-t
dot com slash toast and enter promo code
toast
okay
are you ready for the past five stories
pops i'm ready all right i'm ready
freddie first up the big news is that
kylie jenner has changed the name of her
baby did you know that yeah didn't that
happen like a couple days ago yeah well
we haven't done the show since monday
so kylie jenner shares a new photo of
her baby boy before announcing that his
name is no longer wolf so she posted
this really really sweet um like
documentary that they put together they
did it for stormy too on her youtube
channel was really sweet like i did find
myself tearing up when all the sisters
were just like talking to the camera
giving kylie advice and then she wrote
fyi our son's name isn't wolf anymore
emoji emoji we just really didn't feel
like it was him just wanted to share
because i keep seeing wolf everywhere
yeah you keep seeing wolf everywhere
because you told us that was his name
and then you didn't tell us you changed
it so of course that's what we're going
to say like totally you tell us it's a
kid's name we're going to go with that
correct so i feel like this like we need
to normalize changing your mind yeah
it's not that crazy we did it
right we got our beautiful theo i looked
at him and i said because again by the
way i think that this it's a lovely
origin story his name we call each other
moof moofy so
it was a perfect name for our son
but obviously that's a horrific name for
a dog so
after
naming him movie we switch to theo
because he is obviously a theo yeah that
was like a weird thing we did it was it
was but formalized changing your mind
and that was with a dog like imagine a
real human oh my god i'll never look at
you the same no but you know that was
with a dog no but like a a child's name
follows them throughout their life it
has so much meaning it's like how people
perceive them they sometimes kids get
bullied ben's soccer like you know yeah
do you know how much theo would have
been bullied if his name was movie he's
a completely different dog
that dog that tried to
hurt him at the park remember that one
time no remember when theo was under
siege yes that was not good that red
rocket almost went right in his booty
yeah that was terrible um but with a kid
like it's really important and so when
we were like helping jackie pick out
names for harry like it's such a huge
undertaking like i don't know how you
name a child it's also so stressful like
every single time i said a name like i
just know that it was bothering them
totally like like
like parents don't really want your
recommendations on names like it's a
discussion but like it's like it's their
child it's their decision like
you know true no it's so true like it's
like oh we were talking about it but
like i don't think our opinions had any
weight no no honestly the opposite if i
recommended a name they automatically
hate it gone yeah no you're oh ben's
i also think like it is us overstepping
to like suggest names for sure it's not
our kid no
we're on our business actually i was
going to ask you but excuse me the
coughing i forgot to take my zyrtec this
morning
oh really zyrtec please send me more i
don't
want you to say like what names you like
because like people are always stealing
names like what names do you like mm-hmm
are you like a girl
let's go oh no by the way i can't people
are going to steal it yeah but do you
have like names and you have some names
that i like you do yeah oh i didn't know
that i have some names that i like give
me one no we we like the same names we
do we've talked about some names okay
we're on the same name length yeah
totally totally i trademarked that name
um so happy for kylie normalize changing
your mind
these are really big decisions to make
and sometimes you name your kid and the
kid comes out and it's like you're not a
wolf no but by the way
no one has ever birthed a child and they
were a wolf yeah it's such like an
intense name yeah like
i'm sorry i agree you should be able to
be renamed wolfe at like the age of 16.
you know it's like grow up are you a
wolf or are you not a wolf because if
you are
then
your name could be you can't grow into a
wolf no yeah like you either are or
you're not i completely agree yeah it's
really crazy name so and there's only
one wolf in the world do we know what
name they've chosen
no that's the thing she hasn't told us
yet yeah that is the only wolf taylor
lautner is the only wealth um but she
hasn't told us the new name and i'm just
like quaking like what is it like is she
gonna stick with the same like intense
vibe or maybe he's not an intense child
you know maybe he's like super peaceful
so his name will be like you know
solomon you know what's interesting
they named their daughter stormy and
stormy when you think about it is an
intense word storm but they put the i
softened it now it's like a sweet word
so maybe they were planning on doing the
same with wolf where it was like an
intense word
but
make it less intense that's an
interesting analysis i never thought of
it that way well like maybe like
take thunder take this with a silent k
yeah take the fear out of wolf maybe
with w-o-l-p-h
oh even though she did say w-o-l-f yeah
i mean she should have listened to me
but that's stunning
i like that a lot
yeah yeah i think that's a good take i
like it um so we'll just be sitting here
with you know our fingers up our ass
waiting for her to tell us the new name
i'm not doing that ever again
okay um let's go into some
conservatorship news i know you're a
really big fan of amanda bynes
um and she has been flooded
i'm not a big fan of amanda vines but i
do often reference you're not i was a
fan this knew amanda ben don't be mean
she's going through a hard time you
really think so yes well listen i know
you haven't been keeping up but let me
tell you she's been flooded with tv
offers now her conservatorship has ended
so she's been in a conservatorship like
britney spears like look at us always
putting women in boxes like do you know
any men in a conservatorship no wendy
williams is about to be put in one
always with the successful women so a
different kind of amanda show could be
on the way anyone and everyone in the tv
industry has been trying to get a hold
of amanda bynes after the termination of
her conservatorship her lawyer revealed
on wednesday
he said while amanda's being flooded
with interview offers most of which came
pouring in over the last few days she's
not ready to talk and is laying low for
a while her lawyer shared that several
production companies have also reached
out to amanda's team about filming
documentaries or a potential reality
show on her life moving forward um so
according to her lawyer the new york
times l.a times wall street journal
vanity fair l cbs news gail king and
logan paul
are among those who have pitched
interviews with the former actress
that's according to tmz
um and she hasn't allegedly been offered
any book deals even though that will
definitely be coming
soon so the superior court judge agreed
to end her conservatorship
of her and her estate nearly nine years
after it was established to protect the
star from her struggles with mental
health and substance abuse in the last
several years she said i've been working
hard to improve my health so that i can
live and work independently and i will
continue to prioritize my well-being in
the next chapter
i'm excited about my upcoming endeavors
including my fragrant fragrance line and
i look forward to sharing more when i
can
to me amanda bynes is like
we always we make an example out of like
britney spears and i feel like not a lot
of people talk about amanda bynes
because she kind of like really went
low-key under the radar i didn't even
know she was in a conservatorship no i
just thought that she was batshit crazy
but she's not like she was she went
through a hard time and like literally
her freedom was taken away but the good
thing about this is from what i
understand is that like her family's
totally on her side
and she's like on good terms whereas
like with brittany her family was like
taking advantage of her and draining her
money and they were the ones trying to
keep her in the conservatorship so i'm
really happy i hope she's in a good
place like i
i think like she i was talking about
this with josh peck on friday she like
we were robbed of one of the greatest
comedic actresses of our generation
because i think like the media was so
mean to her it got to her
her her mental health like was not a
priority for her team and like i just
think we were so robbed of an amanda
bynes career yeah your favorite movie
she's a man she's the man the best movie
and like if you watch it and it's like a
funny silly movie but if you watch it
like keeping a keen eye on amanda bynes
like it's oscar-worthy like what was
that movie with uh was she she's a
princess
uh and her no her dad is a is the like
king of england or whatever um what a
girl wants
also what a girl great movie like she
had banger after banger i mean she's the
same as hillary duff like what's the
except funnier no she's in my opinion
like more of a star than hillary duff
yeah she could have been mm-hmm she
could have been so honestly like as much
as i would love to see her return to the
screen like i just want peace for amanda
bynes like i just want her you know to
have her money i hope she can just like
retire peacefully
fall in love take care of her mental
health like i just i'm really happy
about this the most shocking part about
what you read is that she's launching a
fragrance line and it's like
what is wrong with people that are
pitching celebrities fragrance lines
like who's going to buy the amanda bynes
post-conservatorship fragrance well the
thing i can't make something that's
actually unique to her the thing is is
that i think amanda bynes just might be
like like stunted a little in
like when she came up when she was like
16 17 18 and she was a huge star
fragrances
were making yeah billions of dollars kim
kardash every celebrity had a fragrance
like the first big thing kim ever did
after like outside of her sisters was a
fragrance like there was a time where
fragrances were literally like gold
mines so i think that because she hasn't
worked in a while and she's been like in
this conservatorship i think she might
be stunted a little and just like where
she thinks like celebrity
brands are and maybe she's like still
stuck in like the 2000s that's what i
think i i think that there's no shot
that that was her idea
oh i mean i don't know i hope she's in
charge of her own business now like
there's no way that she said end
conservatorship i'm launching a
fragrance i actually like i could see
that for amanda she's not like other
girls interesting i love her like i will
buy the fragrance i love her well that's
nice of you yeah i won't be buying the
fragrance but if she
i don't know a soccer brand
yeah totally like a lot of jerseys line
of jerseys homage to she's the man yeah
like bring back the old amanda like
welcome to o'leary yeah hold on
welcome to illyria welcome welcome
welcome welcome welcome welcome welcome
welcome welcome welcome to alleria
it's a gorgeous instrument it's gorgeous
yeah where'd you get it it was a gift
actually thank you so much and it's from
um
tree works made in nashville tennessee
usa we love supporting usa companies
awesome um so yes amanda bynes is free
we look forward to seeing what she does
supporting her and giving her all of our
love and support yes
you agree love her okay
rooting for her i don't know why i
thought you were like the biggest amanda
bynes fan
because you grew up on amanda show like
i loved amanda bynes then amanda bynes
seemingly fell off a cliff i feel
terrible now understanding what she went
through what she went through
uh but it certainly shook i haven't i
haven't thought like my amanda bynes has
stuck
12 years right right like there's no i
haven't heard about her like at least
britney's struggles were very so public
public which
made us constantly question
everything is she okay is it her is it
her family what's going on and now we've
led
sort of to
this huge movement it's huge there was a
hashtag right now amanda bynes fell by
the wayside she just fell off a cliff no
and no one spoke about her nobody heard
of her i randomly just saw a video of
her with blue hair and like a bull nose
ring yeah she had like a heart tattoo on
her face and she just like looked
again like different do you but looked
completely different and
and you can anybody can change their
vibe but yeah but she just didn't feel
like funny or right no it was like it's
not funny anymore it's not funny anymore
yeah it felt very dark
um okay
always always rooting for me but like
come on fragrances and also like if
you're looking for an interview like we
will have you at the morning test um all
right next up page six this is like huge
news i don't know if you give a [__] but
bravo is rebooting real housewives of
new york with a new cast oh i care and a
completely new cast and a second show
with ex housewives
so if you haven't been keeping up like
the real housewives of new york has just
been slowly
unraveling like it went from
a decent show no went from a great show
to a decent show to like a bad show to
an unwatchable show to a show that was
so low in ratings that bravo didn't even
air didn't even film a reunion with them
like they didn't even think it was worth
spending the money like it was just so
messy it was so bad
and so they're looking and so a lot with
a lot of the og shows like the real
housewives of orange county they've been
on for so long that a lot of them are
getting to this place where it's like
trash like it's unwatchable and they're
doing different things with orange
county they brought back someone who was
beloved they cut a few people added some
new people got rid of some of og's and
like
it's not great but it's better but i
don't think they were going to take that
approach with new york because it wasn't
a big enough
turnaround in ratings and entertainment
so now what they've decided to do is to
get rid of everyone start with a new
cast they said they're looking for
people um who are potentially related
people who are actually friends
i don't know who that's going to be
but then they're also going to keep
because there's so many gems on the show
ramona people love sonia luanne ex
housewives like dorinda jill zaran
people feel very connected to they're
gonna have a second show like a spin-off
for all the old spinsters
now while this sounds like a good idea
i'm not really sure how the the cure for
a show with low ratings is to start two
shows like you can barely get good
ratings for one show now you're gonna do
two yeah i'm not sure
and the second show like sounds like
they just don't want to fire
all those ladies so they're just going
to give them some show maybe it'll be on
peacock
peacock has actually been really good
for bravo it's a very strange story yeah
i i don't think this is the answer
honestly it's strange because if you
want high ratings
just bring on like one
mega new york person but i guess maybe
they didn't want to maybe like the real
popular people like don't want to do a
show with like these crazies it's very
hard to get women in new york like the
real housewives of new york at the
beginning
it really they did a good job with some
of the women getting
like legit rich people like luanne
delisepps we know her now as like
cabaret star who gets kicked out of bars
but when she was on the show she was an
actual count
countess excuse me her husband was a
count they had a stunning townhouse on
the upper east side like huge estate in
the hamptons a driver things have
changed and now like all the women on
the show are essentially husbands like
sonia morgan was married to jp morgan's
grandson but is not anymore and she has
a townhouse that's like being held
together by a thread it's like not real
rich new yorkers because the actual like
old money people in new york they don't
want to be on this show of course not
it's trash yeah so it's impossible for
them to cast they should really get some
influencers like they should get the
charnes girls like something navy and
her sisters yeah that's a good idea like
they're moms they're married they're
very successful in their own right their
sisters like they would be great
just i don't know what they're gonna do
jackie
jackie yes gary jackie would never but
like by the way she would never until
she got an offer no she would literally
gotta think about it jackie would never
she wouldn't even think about it no like
100 not i would think about it but she
wouldn't
she wouldn't even think about it no
interesting like 100 now
but so like they just need fresh they
need new this is a problem that
housewives as an
industry is running into like they're
kind of aging out like
people like olivia was the first person
on the planet to watch outside she was
obsessed and she hasn't watched in years
like it's just it's dry it's kind of
stale even when it's good it's not like
great and i just don't think that this
is the answer i do think what they did
with real housewives of miami was great
real housewives miami was a show that
was on bravo for like two or three
seasons no three maybe three or four um
it was good it didn't have like huge
ratings but it was really good they got
canceled obviously and then eight years
later they brought it back on peacock
larsa pippins on it they got sick like
people actual money
and it's really good yeah but it's it's
funny like if you think about it in like
a sports analogy athletes don't play
forever right they get replaced by
young talented athletes yeah you retire
like the i think i think the biggest
problem is that these if these women are
passed to their time no you're being
ageist it's not about teenagers because
it's not about age it's really not like
some of the best housewives are in their
60s and the women who are in their 30s
are trash it's not about age it's really
not it's about first of all it's about
money like when you come onto the show
and you have the biggest house the
nicest cars like it gives you status and
for some reason in the last couple years
bravo has not been able to cast women
with real money it's all a facade and
they get into legal trouble gen shah
teresa judith erica jay and like they
get into this legal trouble um so i
think the first thing is money and it
really doesn't have to do with age like
hate her or love her lisa vanderpump was
one of the biggest pot starring [__]
in the country and she's the oldest
housewife she was in her 60s i was an
implying age i was saying that everybody
has a moment in time oh okay and it's
very difficult to keep a moment in time
for more than 10 years yeah i agree move
on
like get get up get a fresh face again
that person can be 80 and cool but
there's just so much like sentiment like
we feel so connected like they don't
want to let go of ramona even though
people have problems with her and she's
not great anymore
you're connected
no i know no i mean you'll still keep up
with her yeah you can
see her other places yeah maybe what
they do is they start bringing og
housewives to reunions
like there's a new new new york new york
house watch what is that new york
household new york yeah how's the house
of new york you know when you say a word
and you're like is that it like is the a
word
so many times it's like garage garage
that literally has happened to me yeah
um
but why can't they bring her
like back on like a future reunion show
like you have like the og housewife
there
yeah there's a way to keep the weight
like maybe she's like hosting the
reunion well no but i know what you mean
yeah they keep like housewives who are
no longer on the show they come on watch
japan's live they do these big watch
happens live in their life
yeah now they're doing real housewives
ultimate girls trip with old uh real
housewives in the berkshires yeah you're
right they could keep them in the
without keeping them in the main show
agreed you're right
i just don't i don't think this is the
answer for bravo i don't but i'm happy
that they're trying out different things
for all these franchises that are like
starting to expire
and we'll see what works oc didn't
really work it worked fine but not great
i don't know if this is going to work so
we'll see what works i think what what
really worked was with real housewives
of
um all right are you ready for the next
story yeah sorry i have a bit of a creek
in my neck do you wanna i'm gonna do an
ad if you want to get up and like walk
around yeah i also could really use the
zyrtec so i'm just gonna well you do the
ad i'm just gonna get some ad bill in a
zert oh yeah go go go okay cool you
really only have like 60 seconds so make
it quick
today's episode is brought to you by
bowl and branch no one wants to cut
corners on what's important and few
things matter more than good night's
rest bowlin branch signature sheets feel
so soft and light you'll forget you're
not actually sleeping on a cloud and
they're sustainably made for
uncompromising quality from field to
factory the signature hem sheets from
bowling branch are a bestseller for a
reason they're buttery soft lightweight
organic cotton in a classic sateen weave
for sheets that get softer over time
it's not too hot it's not too cool it's
the perfect year round sheets for most
sleepers bowling branch focuses on
quality over quantity so there's no
inflated thread counts because more
isn't always better so bowling branch
the signature hem sheets that's what we
have at our house i'm a big bowling
branch girlie all my sheets my throat
blankets everything i have is on bowling
branch i'm a big fan um rach parcell
uses them so like if it's good enough
for rage you can experience the best
sheets you've ever felt at
bowlingbranch.com get 15 off your first
set of sheets when you use promo code
toast to check out that's bowlin branch
b-o-l-l-a-n-d
branch dot com promo code
toast those are our sheets yeah that's
what we have amazing
i'm okay i think you'll like this next
story from the hollywood reporter aren't
you i'm not seeing a lot of people talk
about this
kevin and frankie jonas are to host a
celebrity relative reality show for abc
called claim to fame it will feature 12
non-celebrities looking to make their
own names and win a cash prize
so the network has greenlit claim to
fame a competition show in which 12
people related to celebrities quote step
outside their famous family members
shadow and live together under one roof
concealing their identity and lineage in
the quest for their own fame and fortune
brothers kevin and frankie jonas will
host the show which come from the love
is blind producers kinetic content and
disney's television
in walt disney so claim to fame will be
a big brother style competition in which
12 players are isolated from the outside
world compete in challenges and form
alliances to stay in the game keeping
the identities of their famous relatives
a secret will also be a key part of the
gameplay
the show marks a return to disney for
kevin jonas who along with his brothers
nick and joe rose to fame in the 2000s
with the help from disney channel um i
kind of think that this is like a really
good idea it's definitely interesting
yeah first of all like what is the game
like what is that do you ever watch big
brother
me neither but they put people in a
house and there's all these like
challenges and it's like mental warfare
used to get other people eliminated
while also creating alliances and people
really like it and it's very interesting
so i think like having it be like
celebrity offspring is really cool by
the way this i this like concept of
people really liking shows so we will
like it people really like love is blind
that show is trash no but i have to have
a feeling if i watched like celebrity
big brother i would really like it okay
it honestly sounds like celebrity big
brother because
most of the people in celebrity big
brother are not like really famous it's
like frankie grande ariana grande's
brother by the way this is also
celebrity big brother but without
needing to pay celebrities but still
being able to use their names totally
they literally are just hoodwinking
everyone it's like i don't want to pay
nick and jonas so i'm going to pay nick
and jonah kevin and hussy and nick and
jonas what did i say cute who's mickey
jonas and kevin and husie
what did you just say
i don't want to pay nick and joe so i'm
gonna pay right kevin and frankie and
non-stop talk about nick and joe right
no no you're right this is kind of like
a pulling the wool over everyone's eyes
yeah they literally cut the budget
into half less yeah
i also am really curious who they're
going to cast like is it going to be
people like
okay we know who frankie grande is or is
it going to be like actual people who
have never been seen like me i heard you
know ashton kutcher has a cousin you
know that's who it's going to be yeah it
would be really funny if like six months
later something comes out in the news
like somebody lied about their right
relation to the celebrities yeah i'll go
on the show i'm sienna miller's
long-lost sister yeah
it's true that's actually really funny
yeah and i wonder if the celebrities are
going to be involved at all
definitely
i think not actually maybe for like the
winner
yeah maybe maybe i think it's and i like
that they have frankie and um kevin
hosting it's fun because frankie grande
has become like a major tick tock star
in the recent couple years i think he's
like 3 million followers the gen z's
love him obviously
what is our generation x
millennials
love kevin and i think that this is
great i think it's actually like a
really good idea and i actually might
watch it depending on who the people are
like if i have no idea who they are i
might not but if it's like you know i
don't know why i keep thinking of
frankie jonas but like a relatively
kind of known person
like who is a cousin
of a celeb
yeah i don't know is it like total
nobodies
i need more more clarity
i can't think of one
yeah no me neither
and that makes sense because they're a
celebrity's cousin
why would you know
um okay they have to be total nobodies
yeah i think so too so like who cares
so it's not even celebrity big brother
it's just big brother with random people
big brother with random people who
happen to be like loosely related
loosely related to like influencers yeah
it's like one of those like my my
cousin's sister's boyfriend
was in the army
totally um well best of luck and i'm
happy that frankie and kevin are getting
work outside of singing best of luck
best of luck all right our fifth and
final story is some jeffrey epstein news
his pedophile island has hit the market
for 125 million dollars
so his two private islands commonly
referred to as pedophile island due to
allegations that he sexually abused
girls as as young as age 11 is set to
list for a whopping 125 million dollars
the new york post can confirm it's
located in the u.s virgin islands and
they're known geographically as great st
james and little st james the islands
have been fairly untouched since
epstein's death in 2019.
that wasn't a suicide
um
according to epstein's estate lawyer the
proceeds from the sale are expected to
go toward resolving any outstanding
lawsuits regular costs of
operating the island and other fees
including taxes creditors liens placed
on the properties by the u.s virgin
islands attorney general
and
what's interesting is that epstein
purchased the little st james island
which is over 70 acres in 1998 for seven
point nine million dollars
and now it's worth a hundred and what
was it 25 195
125 yeah who the [__] would buy this
like even if you really want uh a
private island like you're rich enough
and you're shopping and there's oh
there's a sale let's go to this one and
it's obviously a little discounted
because all the [__] that went down
there i don't think i could ever even
though like it's it's pretty sickening
like so one the u.s virgin islands it's
dog [__] in comparison to the british
virgin so true you're gonna spend your
money go british you're right two
it's not discounted it actually seems
like it's a premium well what are 70
acre islands going for now that actually
have estates and mansions already built
on it's a discount you're right it has
to be discounted very discounted no one
would pay top dollar for this no
the thing is can you ever get the
feeling or smell off the island it's
kind of like buying like a house that
somebody was murdered in yeah it's worse
like even if you bulldoze it it's creepy
like hearing the stories of the girls
who would literally jump off the cliff
to try and swim and it was like sharks
everywhere like it was horrible yeah but
now that i am thinking about it like a
hotel chain 125 million you turn that
into a sickening property i don't think
any like any
consumer would really feel comfortable
spending money there like it's so creepy
maybe enough time hasn't passed i was
gonna say i wonder if
like okay so now it's pedo island
once it's re-bought rebranded
most people don't know the coordinates
of the island like they're just like
they see like oh marriott has a new
property and they go they don't know
what it was yeah like we don't know what
was anything you know i'll be very
interested to see like what happens here
if you're right like a marriott buys it
i just don't think anyone wants a bad
press like it's not worth having one
good hotel to have like oh yeah we paid
125 dollars to pay off the problem
jeffrey the problem
the problem is the press yeah if the
press wasn't involved and somebody could
just buy it and but i don't think anyone
would even want that like it's so creepy
it's creepy now i'm saying it's just
it's land like i know it was pito island
was probably like the most gorgeous
beautiful st james yeah it's just it's
so weird yeah it's weird it's so creepy
what a conundrum i know
discounted island and he has all these
homes like crazy estates like the one on
the upper east side yeah i think it's
like 78th and madison it's like this
huge that's where he was arrested like
where they found all this evidence all
these tapes like that's a stunning piece
of
architecture it's literally like a
landmark it's one of these old old town
houses like who the [__] would want to
buy that that should just turn into like
a government building yeah like there's
just not
i don't think there's a buyer for these
places he has all these crazy states one
in like cleveland like it's crazy what
if he turned it into like
and he didn't have kids right what did
he turn into like a school
yeah i mean
no a school
yeah i get what you're saying but like
for no no no no no no no no i meant more
honestly should be like a prison like
doing something for good no but you
don't want to waste an island on a
prison no you're right it should be like
a shelter like something yeah yes i know
what you meant something gorgeous and
nice yeah like maybe you like yeah i i
understand right now yeah no but i
understand what you're trying to say
like trying to turn you know the bad
fortune into good fortune yeah like
people would love a beautiful island
yeah or like make it like an island for
like people that can't afford an island
yeah no i know what you're saying like
turn it around yeah turn it around turn
around turn it turn around turn around
turn around turn around
turn it around
turn the beat around
[Music]
love to hear percussion
sorry i'm just like obsessed with my
little instrument so jeffrey epstein's
island is being sold i will be watching
the story with a very keen eye like what
happens i wonder if anything we
predicted here on the show like might
happen we predicted nothing no i know um
well those are the fast five stories i
feel as though you needed to know them
and today's episode is truly far from
over
because it's deer toasters and that's
just the best usually on wednesdays used
to be on tuesdays i don't know i'm like
feeling very all over the place but
today i wanted to do it because i feel
like you really do give good advice and
it's brought to you by zocdoc a free app
that shows you doctors who are patient
reviewed takes your insurance and are
available whenever you need them you can
read up on local doctors get verified
patient reviews see what other real
humans have to say about their visit so
when you walk into the doctor's office
you're set up to see someone in your
network who gets you go to zocdoc.com
choose a time slot and whether you want
to see the doctor in person do a video
visit and then just like that you're
booked every month millions of people
are using zocdoc we're one of them it's
my go-to whenever i need to find and
book a doctor and since i travel so much
for work it's stunning because you've
never had strep throat in the middle of
detroit and your phone is literally your
best friend getting you amoxicillin like
zocdoc is perfect for anyone
it really is helpful in finding good
doctors in your network so you can pay
with insurance um they take insurance
they understand your needs and they're
available when you can see them zocdoc
is pain free go to zocdoc.com toast and
download the zoc doc app for free then
start your search for a top-rated doctor
today and a lot of them are available
within 24 hours that's
z-o-c-d-o-c dot com
toast zoc doc dot com slash toast okay
ready for dear toasters our advice
segment where you can write in totally
anonymously and we will give you our
best advice help you get through
whatever you're going through if you
ever want to write in it's dear toasters
gmail.com
dear claudia and jackie or the guest
that's you
oh ow i'm gonna just put myself in the
eye okay i'm a single girl in my 30s
trying to find love on the apps again i
match with this guy a few weeks ago and
we have plans to go on a date in two
weeks if i'm being honest he was a six
out of ten in looks from his tinder
profile but he seemed like an overall
great guy that we might have some
similar interests the problem is i did
some online stalking and i found his
facebook where i scanned through his
photos and found him to be more like a 4
out of 10 looks wise i know this sounds
shallow but now i'm second guessing the
date he took the initiative to pick the
time in place and he seems like a great
guy who really wants to meet me but i
have a gut feeling there will not be an
attraction on my end when we meet what
should i do do i still go and give it a
shot or do i follow my shallow gut and
not waste my time sincerely a
30-something girl who's not getting any
younger okay i have a few things to say
the first thing is that you should 100
go on this date because one
nothing bad really can come from a date
like it's always good practice to go on
a date
you met him on online so just make sure
you go somewhere public make sure you
know nothing
scary can happen but if it's just like a
standard date there's nothing really bad
that can happen it's always good to you
know practice up on your dating skills
and you really
never know and the thing is with looks i
just don't believe in looks you know
like
a person is as beautiful in your eyes it
really is true like beauty is in the eye
of the behold what do they say beauty is
in the eye of the beholder like
when you meet someone and you have great
vibes like you will think that they're
good looking like i really firmly
believe that i just i think that like
the beauty standard unless he's like a
gremlin but like the beauty standard is
just like not real like i just think you
should 100 go on this date yes
and i've heard a million stories of
girls like oh man i almost didn't go and
then you know like they were saying that
at the wedding like yeah i was gonna get
and then you gotta laugh so you never
know yeah what were you gonna say i was
just gonna say
one if you agree to go on a date go on
the [__]
it's really really [__] up to cancel
dates and i know it usually happens on
the at least i hear it on the guy's side
the guy canceled the date on the girl
it's not nice you agree to go on a date
go on a date worst thing it's dinner you
want you were going to eat anyways yeah
or you were going to see a movie you
might not have to pay yeah or if you do
you were going to pay for dinner anyways
because you're single it's true you need
them to pay
you don't eat for free no it's true so
so go on the date um i would say
don't go into it with a bad attitude
like looking for your boyfriend
go into it like looking to have a good
time because i totally agree with you
that you absolutely can fall in love
with someone and end up finding them
attractive that you didn't
but not if you're going into it looking
to date them it's more if you're going
into it looking to be their friend and
then all of a sudden it turns into
something more yeah do you understand
what i'm saying i do but like sure yeah
i do i do i do the only look if two
people are trying to date
they need to be physically attracted to
each other no but you never know she
hasn't even met the guy yet no but the
stories about how you have like one
that's significantly better looking than
the other is always oh they were best
friends in high school and they grew
together and now they're married right
right oh they were best friends here
best friends there it's very rare that
you have two people that are on opposite
ends of the look spectrum falling madly
head over heels in love the minute that
they meet when they were intending to
date so you think she should go into
this looking for a friend i think that
she should go into this looking for
really good conversation okay and see if
he's really funny and if she finds that
physically attractive also keep in mind
that like boys don't care about photos
they don't edit them they just like get
clearly this guy does
tinder profile she's saying is much
better than much better we've been from
a six out of ten to a four out of ten
that's a lot no it's not i just think
like just go just go okay go go if you
want if you want to date and you want to
end up in a relationship you got to
leave your house definitely go also if
you agreed to the date before you
started stalking him why'd you stalk him
what's the point running anyways yeah
you're only saving yourself you're only
setting yourself up for failure a
hundred percent leave it alone also do
you find it on facebook because if it's
facebook he probably hasn't updated them
in nine years she said facebook yeah
yeah no i don't i just don't think guys
social media is ever accurate of how
they look facebook certainly yeah
instagram they're always like just
taking pictures of like like sunsets
like it's not a thing
i don't even know what that means well
not you okay next up okay hey girlies
ben i live and die for this podcast so
it only makes sense to solicit advice
from the two most beautiful stunning and
smart girls around that's us that's
beautiful okay so my boyfriend of eight
years and i recently moved in together
he's a total p john but of course moving
in together sheds light on habits that
each other has that we may not have been
aware of before and i think i found his
only major flaw
he's a booger flicker
aren't we all they're everywhere now
don't get me wrong everyone's got to
pick their nose i'll admit even i do it
sometimes but i always make sure to use
a tissue to keep everything hygienic but
i'm finding this man's boogers
everywhere on walls dressers blinds
literally every day i find a booger
in the least place in the place i least
expect it to the first one
one or two times i pointed it out to him
and called him gross and we both laughed
about it but now it's reaching a
disgusting level and i'm not sure what i
can do he's my future husband and i love
him to pieces but this is going too far
and frankly it's making me look at him
in a different light any advice on how i
can bring it up more seriously to him
and maybe help him develop more sanitary
nose picking habits thank you number one
are you feeling shame buy a magic eraser
they're great are you feeling shame
right now i'm not feeling shame because
it sounds like i wrote this in yeah well
you also are like the biggest nose
picker on the planet and did you ever
see my boogers anywhere no no because
i'm clean i understand you i don't care
if you pick your nose
so i'm actually a big fan of normalizing
nose picking like it's it's what we got
to do but you and your boogers on the
shower wall
i totally disagree with normalizing nose
picking they create sinus infections and
get dirt up in the sinus cavity it's
actually a terrible so stop doing it you
pick your nose all the time no i sneeze
without covering my mouth all the time
that is why you'll often find my boogers
not often occasionally find my body
often on a shower wall because when i'm
in the shower and i need to sneeze
i literally went in the middle of this
podcast to go and take a zyrtec i'm
clearly an unwell man you need to i need
to sneeze you need to see someone i
sneezed
and i guess a booger left my nose and
hit the wall so how does it make you
feel that your wife oh by the way we're
talking about we should be talking about
her no i'm talking about me now okay how
does it feel that your wife who works so
hard to make this house a home
who loves you who works hard at her job
and comes home and cleans and does the
groceries
has to spend some time out of her week
with her magic eraser scrubbing your
bloody boogers off the wall like how
does that make you feel as a man it
makes me feel like we're even because
when you get in bed you don't leave for
nine hours and i'm your personal slave
so i'm sorry that i occasionally sneeze
and a booger ends up rogue it's not
occasionally like it's a lot
okay did you write this
shockingly i didn't okay well what's our
advice to this girl we have to give her
advice how to bring it like honestly you
have to talk to them like no advice to
her yeah by the way just leave it leave
it i keep dropping this book advice to
her is
it's it's not like a
so funny that there's boogers like say
look man
i don't like cleaning up your boogers
please
do your best
to not do that like have it be okay i'm
gonna take your advice look man i don't
like cleaning up your burgers please do
your best to not do that look man i
don't like getting up in the middle of
the night to get you a [__] seltzer
how about you
get up and get your own [__] seltzer
again if there's a good trade right
right i don't know the circumstance in
their relationship yeah if this man is
waiting on that woman hand and foot two
in the morning i need advil two in the
morning i need seltzer two in the
morning i need a ritz cracker then
i think the trade of the occasional
using the magic eraser to peel a booger
off the wall is not as egregious but if
this man is not waiting on this woman
hand and foot she waits on him hand and
foot and has the occasional
booger to peel off
with a magic eraser yeah
dense problem okay i think that's a good
analysis fair yeah relationships are all
about balance they are yeah one booger
equals two seltzers
okay our third and final deer toasters
is something we've never had here before
we have had a boyfriend right in well
for his girlfriend oh
hey girls
ben
i'm a boyfriend and hopefully a pee job
and i'm a boyfriend i'm a huge listener
fan toaster of your podcast and i wanted
to write in on her behalf because she
has vented about this issue to me for
months
quick background my girlfriend moved to
a new city so we're long distance now
and we ended up moving it and she ended
up moving in with a friend in her
previous city she lived alone and
enjoyed it but rent was a lot more in
the new city so she decided to live with
a friend who has a dog fast forward to
now and her roommate has been traveling
for work and or pleasure and it seems
like she's doing it at least two weeks
every month the issue is my instead of
boarding her dog or finding a rotation
of friends who may watch
the dog she always quote asks my
girlfriend to take care of it never
asking if it's okay with her schedule
it's the assumption you know
like you'll watch my dog the roommate
has given zero amounts of money to
compensate but there have also been
damages the dogs has caused that have
not been rectified as well this guy's
definitely a lawyer my girlfriend loves
this dog and is good enough friends with
her roommate that she put up with it for
a couple months but now it's past the
point of being considered of being
inconsiderate in our opinion i've
suggested that she just talk to her
head-on about it but i know that
probably that's probably the guy in me
and would probably make her living
situation awkward i'm just the boyfriend
and i know my place to stay out of it
but i hate to see her getting taken
advantage of do you girls have any tips
suggestions on how she should approach
slash address the issue with her
roommate boarding more payment that is
agreed upon or just pull a nancy and be
like no p.s you should make
wait you should make a male translated
map oh you should make a male translated
map
key of all your acronyms it took me way
too long to figure out what pjama stands
for thanks in advance okay this is tough
like this girl's definitely being taken
advantage of and honestly like she just
has to be like no
so what i would say is
if it's not
your dog
you should not have to watch it for free
multiple weeks weeks yeah a month yeah
it's insane because no matter how much
you love the dog it's a burden at the
end of the day it's a burden
responsibility 100
and we know you can't enjoy a day out
necessarily or you can't go away for a
weekend or you can't because
beautiful pooches have needs yeah they
rely on us to go to the bathroom et
cetera if the girlfriend's listening to
this i would tell you you're being
totally taken advantage of and you're
being taken for a ride getting free um
like dog sitting yeah so either talk to
her about it be like honestly like you
don't even ask anymore and like it's
kind of a big responsibility and like i
have a life too or you could just take
the route of being like a [__] and
being like no and you would be totally
justified in doing that too but i would
that that works what i would say is
just to the first question boarding [__]
no yeah no don't have the dog if you're
on board the dog two weeks out of the
year that's the thing don't have a dog
if you don't have like a good backup
plan like i feel we feel we're very
blessed that like
when we travel either for work or for
pleasure like theo has a safe place that
he arguably likes better than our house
that's your parents yeah and if we
didn't have that he would come with us
right like
i would never ever ever
board theo two weeks well i wouldn't
board him at all yeah boarding you never
know what goes down at those places like
it's always better to leave with a
family or a friend i'm not a fan but if
you have to figure out a situation which
i mean figure out a solution because
clearly clearly you have a situation on
your hands
figure out how much it would have been
to board the dog this is one option
and then get compensated for it but
maybe you shouldn't pat her pockets that
would be weird no i just don't think
this girl who has a dog should be
traveling two weeks out of the month
when she doesn't have a real
plan but maybe she asks you for work so
what she should do is she should find a
dog walker
that can walk the dog you know like they
should have a conversation about it yeah
no like it's not the problem honestly
this girl did not doesn't have a dog and
dogs are responsibilities that's true
and it's not her [__] responsibility
since then she moved into apartment and
got this big job that sucks it's not
your [__] fault no so either start
making up a lot of excuses like she's
gonna be like oh i'm walking well i'm
leaving can you watch molly no actually
i'm going to a farm upstate with my
boyfriend yeah oh no sorry i can't my
boyfriend's coming to visit and we're
sitting at a hotel oh no i can't i'm
going to visit my boyfriend like and by
the way clearly this woman doesn't give
a [__] about her dog yeah like you
should offer i have another idea take
the dog take the dog i'm taking the dog
the dog's now yours yes say if you're
gonna leave it with me two weeks of the
year it's my dog yeah no that's that's
good i'm so happy to take care of it
yeah but it's my dog it's irresponsible
my dog like you have to be able to live
your life and also have a dog of course
but you also have to have like a safe
place for the dog the dog is not an
afterthought like
you need a family member a friend who
cares about the dog someone you trust
it's my dog now yeah i think that's the
most i think you should take the dog my
dog now but you're definitely being
taken advantage of so do one of the
things we said yeah and you have a
pigeon boyfriend so like yeah nice
that's that's all that matters like he
wrote into your toasters
he's a man of taste and style and values
yes that was dear toasters if you ever
want to write in it's dear toasters at
gmail.com that was our show ben thank
you for joining us thank you darling i
love you very much i love you more we're
back tomorrow for friday's episode with
hannah berner first time
gal on the podcast let me have a whole
other week i actually have the next
couple weeks already scheduled with
second and guests so many of you that
you guys have requested so if you all
have requested specific people like i
most likely got them so don't worry um
tomorrow with hannah burner i'm excited
to talk to her and that's all she wrote
cool thank you so much for listening to
the morning toast the millennial morning
show where we deliver the fast face
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast and we're podcasts can be
found on spotify itunes stitcher public
radio i heart cast box all the places so
every lesson podcast find out more until
65 star review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are hope you guys
have an amazing day and we'll see you
tomorrow bye
you